you need to surround yourself with
positive energy positive people things
that bring you up because running the
business is hard enough you don't need
to have negativity around you that will
only bring you down hi I'm Evan
Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and recently a friend of
mine forwarded me an article about this
young Norwegian girl who was 24 years
old and went to Dubai on business and
ended up getting raped and somebody
mixed something in her drink and she
woke up and she was you know getting
raped and as if that wasn't bad enough
she reported it to the police and they
arrested her because it's illegal in
Dubai to have sex outside of marriage
and the only way to recognize rape is if
either the rapist comes forward or four
men of Muslim faith say that they saw it
happen and I got so frustrated and angry
at this situation you know like imagine
being that girl you're going somewhere
on business it's just trying to get a
deal done and to have that happen to you
like it as if that wasn't bad enough to
then report it to the police thinking
you're doing the right thing and they're
the ones throwing you in jail it just
blew my mind and it ruined their work
the rest of my afternoon I couldn't
focus I knew I had stuff to get done and
I was I was doing it but it wasn't the
way I should be working and I told my
friend don't serve me this stuff anymore
because running the business is hard
enough and I try as much as possible to
avoid negativity avoid negative people
avoid negative news you have to pay
attention to the negative things in your
business you know somebody's saying
something bad about your company if a
customers had a bad experience okay you
can't just say hey life is great I'm
gonna ignore these people you have to
take care of the problem but if it's
something like this that has nothing to
do with yourself or your business then
I'd rather not know about it I'd rather
be able to try to surround myself with
people and news and information that is
positive and uplifting because it makes
me feel better and it makes me more
productive I haven't watched the evening
news and maybe 10 years
because it's mostly negative it's all
the negative stuff that's happening in
the world and I'd rather not know about
it and that may sound like I'm ignorant
and not knowing about worldly events and
I'm okay with that I'm okay to be
ignorant on some things I know my
business and know the people that I care
about really well because it makes me
feel better it makes me happier it makes
my business stronger and so I'd
encourage all of you to shut out the
negativity in your life as much as
possible but there's negative people
around you or people sharing negative
news with you all the time just shut
them out phase them out because they're
not bringing you anything that's going
to help you you want to create an
environment by the people you meet by
the websites you read by the TV shows
that you watch by the books that you're
reading right now you want to surround
yourself with things that bring you up
they give you ideas that motivate you
that make you want to be a better person
to help you become the best entrepreneur
you can be so that's my little rant for
the day for those of you watching if you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up I always love seeing those come in
and please leave a comment below it
really is one of the best parts of my
day seeing your comments come in
underneath so if you have a comment
about this video or question for your
own business I'd love to try to help
please leave a comment and I'll see you
on the next episode